can you speak to kind of the process of
writing and designing a great prompt as
you steer gpt4 I'm not good at this I've
met people who are yeah and the
creativity the kind of they almost some
of them almost treat it like debugging
software
um but also they they
I've met people who spend like you know
12 hours a day for a month on end at on
this and they really get a feel for the
model and a feel how different parts of
a
prompt composed with each other like
literally The Ordering of words this
yeah the Clause when you modify
something what kind of word to do it
with
yeah it's so fascinating because like
it's remarkable in some sense that's
what we do with human conversation right
in interacting with humans we'll try to
figure out
like what words to use to unlock uh
greater wisdom from the other the other
party the friends of yours or a
significant others uh here you get to
try it over and over and over and over
you could experiment yeah there's all
these ways that the kind of analogies
from humans to AIS like breakdown and
the parallelism the sort of unlimited
rollouts that's a big one
yeah yeah but there's still some
parallels that don't break down there is
some kind of deeply because it's trained
on human data there's um it feels like
it's a way to learn about ourselves by
interacting with it some of it as the
smart and smarter it gets the more it
represents
the more it feels like another human in
terms of um
the kind of way you would phrase a
prompt to get the kind of thing you want
back and that's interesting because that
is the art form as you collaborate with
it as an assistant this becomes more
relevant for now this is relevant
everywhere but it's also very relevant
for programming for example